all right here we go
curiosity
a strong desire to know or learn
something
curiosity is incredibly practical is how
i see it in my mind these days
everyone's always asking me about how
i hit things early
why
i see around corners like i'm curious
grounded in humility just because i did
well in this or that doesn't mean i'm
going to be great today or tomorrow
curiosity and humility are massive and
so many of you need to add those two
elements to your game it's how you find
early and win
i wonder how big a business i can
actually build i wonder how many people
i could have an impact on i wonder how
many will show up to my funeral one day
you need to have a strong desire to
continue learning no matter how much
you've accomplished i listen and then i
talk a lot people like he's always
talking interrupting i'm like i'm
listening you guys know it's all
listening in my mind i'm still young
i'm still just getting started
i'm still in the dirt if you have an
inflated ego
curiosity gets suppressed
when you don't know and you don't know
what the rules are and you don't know
how it's supposed to be done you start
innovating and creating if you don't
know and you're curious
and you're creative you can really do
some damage and i think that's why i've
been able to continue to do unique
things i use blind eyes a lot and i
protect my blind eyes and i think that
means that i protect my curiosity and
really really
drive from that place
i would tell you that i don't think i
realize how big of a deal curiosity is
in my success
curiosity is the element to unlock what
you're asking
the word curiosity is underrated in our
society it feels fluffy academic and
childish but i believe it's one of the
most important characteristics for
success
are you actually pushing yourself are
you actually learning
are you taking advantage
of the power of curiosity
are you letting fear and lack of
optimism control you or you're going all
in on the things you're actually curious
about to create your next chapter
today was a good day
a day i'll never forget
curiosity
leads you to places you don't expect to
end up
good places
[Music]
you